ich habe selbst recial Profiling erlebt
und deswegen kann ich das bestätigen
dass das Rassismus war der Polizei gibt
es gibt kein strukturellen Rassismus bei
der Polizei Einzelfälle definitiv ja und
die werden auch konsequent verfolgt es
reicht mir eine Person die das
strukturell ausübt für mich ist
strukturell flächendeckend als völlig
legitimes Vorgehen hat die deutsche
Polizei einen Rassismusproblem ja ganz
klar sagt Tarek all aus der ist Aktivist
Jurist und Betroffener alles nur
Einzelfälle meint wiederum Manuel
Ostermann der als Polizist sagt die
deutsche Polizei ist nicht strukturell
rassistisch
ich werfe meinen Gegenüber vor dass er
einfach das Leben nur mit seiner
Weltbild sieht es gibt recial Profiling
es gibt Polizeigewalt es gibt Rassismus
bei der Polizei ich bin selbst zur Opfer
geworden ich glaube nicht dass seiner
Position dass es sich ist sondern bin
ich mir sicher
[Musik]
wir haben kein strukturelles
Rassismusproblem in deutschen
Sicherheitsbehörden und wir haben auch
kein Polizei Problem ich werfe dem Tarek
vor dass er viel zu pauschalisierend
irgendwelche populistischen
diskreditierungskampagnen mit
unterstützt die Kolleginnen und Kollegen
in Frage stellen das sollte man ein
bisschen mehr Sachlichkeit und Weitsicht
weiten lassen
[Musik]
eine Realität die deutsche Polizei und
zwei völlig unterschiedliche Sichtweisen
bei mir auf der Couch wir gucken wer
Recht hat
[Musik]
die beiden herzlich willkommen schön
dass Ihr da seid Tarek hallo Manuel hey
mit einem Polizisten auf der Couch wie
fühlt sich das an
mit einem Polizisten in einem Raum das
reicht schon
für welches Gefühl
das ist das Gefühl ich glaube das
passiert
ist es ein gutes Gefühl tatsächlich als
migrantisierte Person in Deutschland
kann ich leider das nicht bestätigen
dass die Polizei mein Freund und Helfer
ist
sitzt dann da der Feind
es hängt von seiner Position ab also
Polizei ist nicht mein Gegner solange
sie mir nichts tun es war wirklich lange
nicht mehr so aufgeregt wie vor dieser
Sendung und weißer deutscher Mann lädt
ein um über Rassismus zu sprechen da
kann unfassbar viel schief gehen und da
finde ich absolut richtig dass es viele
Fragezeichen gibt die habe ich auch mehr
und bin total gespannt was ihr nachher
dazu sagt gehen wir jetzt voll rein in
unser Thema mit einer Aussage der
Antidiskriminierungsstelle dessen Bundes
die schreibt nämlich folgendes
rassistische Diskriminierung werden
besonders häufig auf dem Wohnungsmarkt
beim Zugang zu Clubs bei Bankgeschäften
in der Schule und Hochschulen im
Arbeitsleben und im Kontakt mit der
Polizei gemeldet
Manuel passt das zu deinem Eindruck
ausdrücklich nicht ich sag ganz deutlich
natürlich gibt es völlig inakzeptabel
Fälle von rassistischen Vorfällen
innerhalb unserer Sicherheitsbehörden
aber es sind Einzelfälle und die werden
auch aufgeklärt den eins ist doch klar
niemand gute Rassisten
Sicherheitsbehörden haben und deswegen
glaube ich muss man das ganze
versachlichen und auch mal sagen worüber
reden wir hier eigentlich und was
passiert denn wenn genau so ein Fall
Auftritt natürlich gibt es vereinzelte
Fälle gar keine Frage sie sind aber
weder strukturell und noch werden sie
überhaupt nicht aufgeklärt also dieser
vereinzelte Fälle sind hunderttausende
von Fälle alleine in meiner Beratung
habe ich fast jeden Tag Fälle von
rassistische Polizei Untersuchungen und
Kontrollen ich habe selbst special
Profiling erlebt und deswegen kenne ich
das bestätigen das ist richtig Profiling
gibt das ist Rassismus bei der Polizei
gibt und das ist Polizei Gewalt auch
ich stelle euch jetzt eine Frage zum
Start in unsere Sitzung hat die deutsche
Polizei ein Rassismusproblem ja nein ich
musste gar nicht zählen zwei völlig
unterschiedliche Standpunkte tauchen wir
jetzt tief ein steht bitte einmal mit
mir auf wir brauchen ein bisschen Platz
[Musik]
wir Menschen denken immer wenn wir
irgendwas sagen dann wissen die anderen
schon was gemeint ist aber die
Psychologie hat immer wieder gezeigt
dass das nicht stimmt und deswegen
einmal festnageln worüber redet man
eigentlich schwarz auf weiß hinschreiben
das hilft
ich habe Satzanfänge hier dabei und
bitte euch die jeweils auf euren Tafeln
zu vervollständigen rassismus ist
sind beide fertig fangen wir bei dir an
Max mal vorlesen rassismus ist ein Gift
ein Gift
rassismus ist für die Gesellschaft
völliger Einigkeit
jetzt frage ich mich wenn ihr Rassismus
so völlig gleich seht wo ist dann der
unterschiedliche Blickwinkel auf
Rassismus was glaubst du das sind
meistens ist man sieht man Dinge ganz
anders als in der migrantisierte Person
die andere Herausforderungen hat
ich mache die Differenzierung eben nicht
zwischen optischen Merkmalen und da
müssen halt aufpassen dass wir nicht
pauschal alles als rassistisch
diffamieren und ich glaube da ist ein
kernunterschied zwischen tarikum mir
okay ich sehe immer zwischendurch nicken
von dir weil du zustimmst oder weil du
am Ende dem letzten Satz zustimmt das
ein Kern Unterschied
nee es ist kein kernunterschied es ist
genau dieser Blickwinkel
der hat die Vorstellung der steht da ihr
redet viel mit sie haben sie haben die
Vorstellung du bist ihn ja warum
ich wurde gerne ein bisschen Distanz
behalten okay weiter als Tarik
konsequent gesetzt hat was im ersten
Moment vielleicht etwas
gewöhnungsbedürftig also es hat noch mal
Ausdruck verliehen was für eine
vermeintliche Zurückhaltung er gegen
meine Haltung meine Person oder
vielleicht doch die Institution hat ich
wollte das einfach sicher darstellen
dass wir völlig unterschiedliche
politische Positionen haben und nicht
nur zwei private Personen die einfach
auf einem Bier miteinander diskutieren
dann würde ich sagen Wetter war einmal
um und kommt zum nächsten Satz
die Polizei hilft
[Musik]
ich lasse es frei ja leeres Blatt Papier
ist manchmal Aussage gekräftiger als
eingeschriebener Satz und insofern hat
mich das schon beeindruckt und nicht
unbedingt im positiven ich kann nicht
sagen die Polizei hilft nicht weil an
mehreren Fällen hat die Polizei mir
geholfen ich kann aber auch nicht sagen
die Polizei hilft immer weil
ich habe auch andere Situationen erlebt
wo die Polizei nicht der Helfer war
magst zum Beispiel gehen ich bin in
einer Berliner Bahnhof reingelaufen mit
einer Gruppe von Menschen cemble Sohn
ich war der einzige Person die nicht
weiß und diese Gruppe und wurde von zwei
Polizisten rausgenommen sie wollten mich
kontrollieren und die Begründung davor
war sie können bei mir keine Gefahr
ausschließen ich sah endlich wie heute
ungefähr und für mich war das okay ihr
habt nur mein Aussehen gesehen alleine
aufgrund meines Aussehens könnt ihr
keiner Gefahr ausschließen
in dieser Situation hat die Polizei
nicht geholfen aber
wichtig in dieser Situation war als die
Polizei erfuhr hat dass sich Jurist bin
und dass ich die Kontrolle widersprochen
habe wollten sie mir nicht mehr
durchsuchen sie haben gesagt sie sind
Juristen wir gehen nicht davon aus dass
sie eine Pistole oder ein Messer dabei
okay das heißt sie gingen am Anfang
davon aus dass ich eine Pistole oder ein
Messer dabei hatte Manuel da muss jetzt
direkt fragen also erstmal muss man
gucken in welchem rechtlichen
Zuständigkeitsbereich war das also wie
ist der Bahnhof ein kategorisiert und
die andere Frage die ich mir dann stelle
hat man sich darüber beschwert weil wenn
man sich darüber beschwert hat wird das
auch intern ermittelt das kann ich
garantieren erstmal jetzt der Satz von
Manuel die Polizei hilft allen Menschen
in Deutschland und zwar auslandslos
das manuell die Polizei als Helfer vor
allem bezeichnet hat zeigt mir dass er
in seine Weltbild eingeschränkt ist hier
haben wir jetzt jemand gesagt das stimmt
nicht was möchtest du erwidern und warum
sagst du das ist für dich auch ganz
schnell klar gewesen die Polizei hatten
gesetzlichen Auftrag als unsere
Exekutive und die Polizei ist in
Deutschland einer der höchst
angesehensten Polizeien in der Welt eben
weil sie rechtsstaatliches weil sie
transparent und weil sie offen ist weil
sie vielfältig ist und diverse
Lernprozesse auch durchmacht und der
Mensch der Hilfe braucht die 110 ruft
oder die Polizei vor Ort ist da hilft
die Polizei egal wie er aussieht völlig
egal wo der herkommt egal was der
beruflich macht egal was der beruflich
macht
in Deutschland ist Rachel Profiling
[Musik]
pauschalisierte Anschuldigung mit dem
Ziel der Firmierung
müssen wir mal kurz erstmal sowieso
glaube ich für studiert haben und den
Satz zu verstehen erklärt man im
zwölfjährigen Kind
racial Profiling ist die gezielte
Kontrolle und Grundrechtseinschränkungen
von Menschen nach bestimmten optischen
Erscheinungsbildern die Form und die
Häufigkeit wie das vorgeworfen wird es
einfach grundlegend falsch wir müssen
wissen wo ist die Polizei gerade
zuständig was ist ihre gesetzliche
Auftrag und was gibt denn das
polizeiliche Lagebild das heißt also
Zahlen Daten Fakten aus der
Vergangenheit die nicht zu Leuten sind
die man bestimmtes Bild ab ich sage
nicht ich sage nicht dass es nicht
vereinzelte Fälle von den gibt ich sage
aber auch gleich mit ja die werden
selbstverständlich aufgeklärt habe so
dann kommst du Tarek mit deiner Aussage
Profile in Deutschland ist eine
Lebensrealität für vielen Menschen
einer von denen ist wenn ich ja in einer
Situation viele von denen sind Menschen
die in meine Beratung kommen was heißt
für dich racial Profiling
dass die Polizei mich unter
Generalverdacht
stellt aufgrund bestimmter äußerliche
Merkmale mir war die ganze Zeit bewusst
es geht hier nicht um mich obwohl ich
Teile meiner Geschichte erzählt habe es
geht um die Verantwortung die ich
gegenüber anderen Menschen die solche
Situationen erlebt haben trage ein
Beispiel einer Person kam zu mir von
paar Wochen in der Beratung und meinte
alleine dass ich zehnmal so im Jahr
ungefähr von der Polizei gestoppt wurde
dieser Person hat gesagt damals zehnmal
Kontrollen im Jahr kann ich damit
umgehen aber meine eigene Hoffnung ist
nicht mit Gewalt begegnet zu werden also
du sagst die Leute die zu dir die
Beratungsstelle kommen die haben sich
schon damit abgefunden dass sie
permanent kontrolliert werden der letzte
Wunsch ist dann noch bitte wenn ihr mich
konnte er nicht gewaltsam das klingt
grausam
du findest du wer ist es auch grausam
und ich glaube im übrigen dass vieles
auch hoch sterilisiert wird eben genau
durch diese Pauschalisierung durch die
Anfeindung der Sicherheitsbehörden damit
ich sagen kommt beide mir zurück auf die
Couch wir nehmen noch mal Platz ja helf
den abzubauen
[Musik]
es ist interessant zu sehen wie jetzt wo
es ums Wasser Teilen geht ihr euch
völlig anders begegnet als gerade wo wir
hier eine Flipcharts stand und wenn ihr
miteinander sprecht natürlich weil wir
aber so nicht miteinander kein Problem
haben also es sind in einer
demokratischen Debatte differenzierte
Position die wir vertreten ich muss
damit nicht einverstanden sein innerlich
aber ich finde das bei jedem Menschen
gut der sich einsetzt gab es einen
Moment wo du dachtest Tarek geht gar
nicht was Manuel sagt was er aufschreibt
Profiling tatsächlich wahrscheinlich
waren sie Herr Ostermann mir in der
polizeilichen Kontrolle bisher und haben
das erlebt wo sie dachten es ging um
nichts anderes außerhalb außer meiner
meines Aussehens wenn dieses Empfinden
da ist
dass ich kontrolliert werde aufgrund
meines optischen Erscheinungsbildes und
dann ist er zunächst einmal
moralisch verwerflich aber jetzt fragen
wir und deswegen habe ich das Wort
polizeiliches Lagebild reingebracht es
gibt zum Beispiel Einsätze
Gewaltkriminalität als Beispiel so da
hat man bestimmte bestimmte Banden
bestimmte Tätergruppen die man in der
Vergangenheit festgestellt hat die auch
rechtsstaatlich verurteilt worden sind
und genau nach diesem Prinzip geht man
und versucht präventiv dieser Lage her
zu werden und jetzt komme ich der Punkt
warum ich das sage jede polizeiliche
Maßnahme
ist ein Eingriff in die Grundrechte
einer Person das ist genau richtig
Profiling einfach so auszuwerten wie
eine Person aussieht und Generalverdacht
gegenüber dieser Version zu machen und
die Person zu kontrollieren nur weil er
so aussieht das ist kein Generalverdacht
es ist kein Generalverdacht sie haben
gesagt nach einer Erscheinungsbild wird
es ausgesucht das ist genau was mit mir
passiert und das ist eine Profiling wir
müssen darüber reden in welchem
Zuständigkeitsbereich wir arbeiten denn
dann wird klar ob es welche Profiling
ist oder eine normale polizeiliche
Fakten basierte Arbeit was sagen Sie
Herr Ostermann weil sie nicht auf Straße
gestoppt wurden von der Polizei und nach
dem Kauf nach dem Kaufvertrag ihres
Rennrads gefragt wurden ich laufe nie in
Berlin mit meinem Rennrad ohne ein Bild
von dem Kaufvertrag weil ich öfter
gefragt wurde ob das mir gehört ich
finde man merkt direkt dass hier
unglaublich zuche in dieser Diskussion
ist und genau diese Anspannung möchte
ich jetzt mal für beide greifbar machen
pass auf ich habe euch was mitgebracht
was jetzt das sage ich direkt dazu eine
gewisse körperliche Nähe auch von euch
verlangen wird und zwar dieses
elastische Sportband
[Musik]
jetzt haben wir schon eine ganze Reihe
von Punkten gehört mir ist aber wichtig
dass einmal noch auf den Punkt zu
bringen und dabei möchte ich jetzt bei
aller Konfrontation dass der andere
erstmal einfach nur zuhört nichts
erwidert okay egal was gesagt wird
allerdings müsst ihr nicht völlig
tatenlos bleiben sondern ihr könnt über
dieses Gummiband dem anderen
signalisieren wie sehr euch das gegen
den Strich geht wie sehr ihr sagt nee
passt mir nicht das Leben nicht ab und
zwar indem ihr zurückgeht es geht um die
Frage gibt es strukturellen Rassismus
bei der Polizei in Deutschland nein es
gibt keinen strukturellen Rassismus bei
der Polizei wir haben sehr wohl traurige
Fälle von rassistischen Äußerungen und
tarnen in deutschen Polizeibehörden
deswegen strukturell nein Einzelfälle
definitiv ja und die werden auch
konsequent verfolgt und das ist genau
richtig so es gab einen Moment da bist
du ein bisschen nach vorne wieder
gegangen wo war das also es ist gesagt
wurde es gibt Fälle aber es ist wieder
diese wenn Einzelfall Argument kommt
dann bin ich wieder zurückgekommen und
bei dem Thema lückenlose Aufklärung wir
haben immer noch NSU
wir haben immer noch
Halle auffälle die Hunderttausende
Einzelfälle mit der er immer
argumentiert das sind aber nur alleine
in meiner Beratungsgespräche Hunderter
von Menschen die diese Einzelfälle
darstellen uns gibt so viele
Beraterinnen das heißt 100.000 davon
Einzelfälle
Zug auf dem Gummiband mehr geht kaum da
würde ich sagen kommen wir noch einmal
zusammen und tauschen jetzt die Rollen
jetzt Tarik dass du die Frage
beantworten gibt es in Deutschland
strukturellen Rassismus bei der Polizei
ich wurde nicht ja sagen ich würde sagen
das können wir bestätigen durch der
unabhängige Studie zur Rassismus bei der
Polizei wenn es nicht der Fall ist dann
wird die Studie bestätigen das ist kein
strukturelles Rassismus gibt und wenn es
der Fall wird die Studie bestätigen das
ist Rassismus gibt strukturell bei der
Polizei allerdings diese Studie wurde
von der Polizei und von Horst Seehofer
die ganze Zeit abgelehnt
ist es maximal Zug oder würdest du gerne
weiter zurück ich würde gar nicht weiter
zurück das ist schon so in Ordnung die
Studie ist ein neues Thema warum sagst
du bei der Studie der Forderung nach
einer Studie gehst du soweit zurück weil
ich sage wenn wir eine Studie machen
dann machen wir sie alle umfassend und
zwar in einen extremistischen Bereichen
was natürlich auch den rassistischen
Bereich mit impliziert was würde das
heißen ob es auch Linksextremisten oder
Linksextremisten und natürlich auch der
Bereich des religiösen Extremismus und
wir machen sie ganz einheitlich und zwar
im gesamten öffentlichen Dienst ich bin
auf jeden Fall der Meinung dass einfach
in allen Bereichen das passiert nicht
nur zur Rassismus auf jeden Fall in
einem Bereichen aber ich habe kein
Problem mit dem Finanzamt ich habe ein
Problem aber mit der Polizei beim Thema
Rassismus es ist doch völlig klar dass
wir Fälle davon haben völlig klar und es
muss grundkont sein dass wenn es diese
Fälle gibt die lückenlos aufgeklärt
werden bei solche Menschen haben sich
als würden nichts zu suchen das bedeutet
aber noch lange dass es strukturelles
und das ist der Punkt wie definierst du
denn bitte strukturell was ist für die
strukturell das eine gewisse Anzahl an
Einzelfälle gibt eine gewisse Handlung
gibt wo man sieht es ist in der Struktur
verankert das ist glaube ich so der Kern
unser Differenzierung für mich bedeutet
strukturell
flächendecken und zwar breit verstreut
als völlig legitimes Vorgehen und das
ist es eben nicht es lässt sich glaube
ich nicht jetzt einfach an einem an
einem Punkt festnageln und trotzdem
würde ich diesen Versuch gerne mit euch
einmal wagen wir stellen uns vor 100
Polizistinnen und Polizisten in
Deutschland wie viele von denen müssten
sich rassistisch verhalten damit wir
sagen dass es strukturell wie viele
werden das für euch für mich ist
strukturell während schon drei wenn alle
anders akzeptieren würden Tarek deine
Zahl von 100
es reicht mir eine Version die das
strukturell ausübt eine von 100 die das
einfach die ganze Zeit ausübt hier
reicht ein Prozent um von strukturell zu
sprechen wo du sagen würdest das nenne
ich doch niemals strukturell und das
glaube ich gerade deswegen so ein
zentraler Moment weil uns hier klar wird
es geht auch ganz viel darum was wir als
strukturell betrachten und um dieses
Wort oder ja also ich finde das einfach
wichtig weil strukturell bedeutet
Behörden durchzogen ein Polizist der
Gewalt und Recht und Profiling immer ist
kein Einzelfall weil der Macht 100 Fälle
am Tag okay und das sind die Fälle
worüber wir sprechen und nicht nicht
einer Person aus der Behörde ihm
tatsächlich auch ganz gut Fairness
halber meine Argumentation noch mal ein
bisschen zu interpretieren für sich und
nachzuvollziehen gerne auch zu
hinterfragen weil wir bitte bitte eins
nicht machen dürfen rechtsstaatlich
arbeiten die Menschen pauschal in einer
Ecke stellen
und das passiert mit solchen vorsichtig
ausgedrückten pauschalen Anfeindungen
ich hatte gerade wirklich das Gefühl ist
das ein Moment wo wir deutlich wieder
zusammen gehen können weil klar wird wir
streiten vor allem darüber was jetzt
strukturell heißt hier sitzt keiner mehr
im Raum der sagt es gibt kein Rassismus
bei der Polizei es gibt ihn und du sagst
es sind Einzelfälle wohin gegen du sagst
genau deine Einzelfälle einer von 100
ist aber strukturell
[Musik]
du hast gerade eben gesagt es gibt
durchaus auch Situationen wo du positive
Erfahrungen mit der Polizei gemacht hast
und du warst ja auch am Anfang als es
darum ging die Polizei hilft
du hast das Blatt leer gelassen magst du
mal dann das Blatt jetzt vielleicht mit
dem positiven Erfahrungen füllen also
ich würde sagen die positive Erfahrung
die ich hatte und zwar als ich meine
Bundestagskandidatur zurückgezogen habe
aufgrund von Morddrohungen hast
Nachrichten im Internet
da waren bei mir jetzt da ging bei mir
drei Monate lang die Hölle los und da
habe ich gesehen wo das Land Kriminalamt
helfen könnte sie haben mir dabei
geholfen also erstmal finde ich das
großartig dass man sich politisch
engagieren heute Bundestag kandidiert
und mir fehlen ehrlich gesagt die Worte
weil ich das geht überhaupt nicht sowas
und mich freut das wirklich sehr dass du
die teilweise echt schwere Arbeit der
Kolleginnen und Kollegen beim
Landeskriminalamt da so wertschätzt und
ich glaube dafür wird doch mal Danke
zusammen danke schön ich brauche davor
auch keinen Dank weil positive Fehler
muss man auch benennen
und mit der Hoffnung dass die
generalisiert wurden da hatte ich schon
positiven Fall da hatte ich helfe
bekommen aber das ist nicht der Fall
immer deswegen würde ich nie sagen ich
bin gegen die Polizei an sich das habe
ich nie behauptet ich merke an vielen
Stellen dass unsere Gesellschaft viel
progressiver als unsere Institution das
ist das eine die Gesellschaft ist viel
entwickelt in der Debatte unsere
Behörden und Institutionen sind noch ein
bisschen zurück mein Hauptanliegen ist
es ja die Differenzierung zwischen
strukturellen Rassismus und Rassismus in
der Polizei das ist auch ein Unterschied
und wenn ich hingehe und sage ich
diskreditiere und pauschalisieren eine
ganze Börse ist falsch statistische
Erhebung zum Beispiel bei der
Bundespolizei vier Jahre von
2017/20 54000 Mitarbeiter reden wir in
einem Bezugszeitraum von vier Jahren von
genau 54 Fällen sind 0,01% in der
Behörde und jetzt sind wir
das ist doch völlig klar 54 sind 54 zu
viel aber 54 von 54.000 und dann
Bezugszeitraum von vier Jahren sind
alles nur nicht strukturell wir sind
jetzt zahlen Daten Fakten die nicht die
Behörde sich ausgeht und da wird auf
jeden Fall der Dunkelziffer von den
vielen Fällen also ich kann einfach bei
mir sagen weil das sein bis 20 Fälle
wird in einem Fall eingeklagt
nichtsdestotrotz haben wir in beiden
Fällen auch eine ganz persönliche
Geschichte die dazu führt dass sie da
steht wo ihr heute steht da wollen wir
jetzt rein dafür brauchen wir dieses
Kissen und ich brauche vor allem euch
beide ich bin sehr sehr gespannt ob das
funktioniert was ich mir jetzt
vorgenommen habe wir müssen noch einmal
ein bisschen Platz Mann Tisch weg würde
mir völlig reichen
und das machen wir im Liegen
wobei nur der eine liegt und zwar auf
dem Kissen auf dem Bein vom anderen
Tarek dreimal durchatmen kriegen wir das
hin
Tarek wie viel Platz brauchst du
so wäre es okay sich dahin zu setzen ja
ja ich gebe ein besonderen emotionalen
Moment
aus eurer jeweiligen Lebensgeschichte
rein und dann kannst du ab da gerne
alles weiter Fragen mir ist nur eins
wichtig hierbei jetzt wir wollen
einander verstehen wir wollen eigentlich
überhaupt nicht angreifen sondern
wirklich gucken warum Manuel damit
zumindest der Kopf nicht ganz untergeht
Tarek gut du sagst stop ne es ist der 4
märz 2009 und unser kleiner Manuel
damals noch Schüler bekommt den Brief
auf den er so lange gewartet hat wie
wahrscheinlich jeder Harry Potter Fan
auf den Hogwarts Brief wartet denn jetzt
steht da drin dass du die
Ausbildungsstelle bei der Polizei
bekommen hast und dein größter Traum
geht in Erfüllung ich kriege gerade mit
Gänsehaut weil ich finde so viele Träume
wie so geil die die Freundin kennen
laufen dir runter übers Gesicht und du
bist voller Glück das ist der Start
Moment fangen wir damit an
was war genau der Traum
wollte schon seit ich denken kann
eigentlich
Polizeibeamter sein mein Onkel der hat
mich damals mitgenommen der ist selber
Polizist und seitdem konnte ich mir
beruflich nie was anderes vorstellen
bei Hauptantrieb ist tatsächlich
unsere Demokratie zu schützen für die
Menschen da zu sein und klar als kleines
Kind ne das ist natürlich super Polizist
mit cooler Uniform und coolem Auto war
natürlich der das Hauptargument damals
als kleiner Junge aber
wie fühlen sie sich dann wenn sie wissen
dass es Menschen Angst vor der Polizei
haben gibt er ist natürlich schade und
traurig wenn Menschen Angst vor der
Polizei haben
ich sag ja schon aus eigener Überzeugung
die Gründe müssen aufgeklärt werden aber
ich sage auch aus einer Überzeugung dass
das Bild was ich als Kind hatte und was
ich selber auslebe mich nicht trügt also
wenn du keine Fragen hast hätte ich noch
welche ich habe keine Frage Tarek will
keine weiteren Fragen stellen und ich
glaube nicht weil er nicht interessiert
ist sondern weil ihm ganz wichtig ist
dass er manuell in seiner Rolle als
Stellvertreter der Polizei sieht und
dieser Polizei wirft er strukturellen
Rassismus vor der ist ihm völlig egal
woher Manuel kommt und was der schon mal
erlebt hat Tarek möchte über die Sache
reden und das finde ich ganz ganz
richtig und trotzdem reden hier zwei
Menschen deswegen ich jetzt noch mal
tiefer Manuel Geschichte reingehe gab es
schon Momente wo du sagen würdest da
hast du dich als Polizist rassistisch
verhalten
nein
rassistisch nicht aber vielleicht hätte
man das kommunikativer damit meine ich
in keinster Form irgendwelche Äußerungen
über Aussehen Geschlecht oder sonst was
sondern einfach in dem
adressatengerechten Sprache so nennt man
es der Person gegenüber ist völlig klar
ist ein Lernprozess natürlich
Tarek du hast gerade eben gesagt du bist
hier um darüber zu reden was was dir
passiert ist was du für Erfahrungen
gemacht hast und auch wo du eben stehst
du hast jetzt absolut die Chance
verdient dass wir einmal die Position
tauschen und das tun sie erzählt was du
erlebt hast was du in Deutschland erlebt
hast was deine vielleicht auch wenn
schon Vorstellung von unserem Land sind
[Musik]
Tarek von Damaskus aus in den Libanon
von dort in die Türkei und dann mit dem
Schlauchboot nach einigen Umwegen noch
nach Lesbos es ist Mitte August 2015 in
diesem Schlauchboot
was erlebst du da und damit würde ich
gerne deine Geschichte starten
ich war damals mit zehn weiteren Person
in diesem Boot es gab keinen Platz und
es sollte eine 11 Person mit uns
einsteigen damals gab es einen Streit
dass kein Platz für Eltern 11 Personen
geben kann dann muss er das Boot selbst
fahren und da war da war für mich das
Moment wo ich dann entschieden habe das
Boot selbst zu fahren
Manuel jetzt deine Chance Tarek zu
verstehen was man deine Gedanken als du
mit dem Boot über die Mittelmeer Rute
versucht hast
irgendwo hinzukommen wo Du wo Du sicher
bist naja Hoffnung ein sicheres Leben
und ein Leben in wurde zu haben wo ich
mich keiner Gedanken über meinen
eigenen Sicherheit haben muss wie wäre
deine Kindheit in Syrien also ich bin in
der politischen Familie geboren und
aufgewachsen mein Vater waren
politischer Journalist meine Mutter war
Buchhalterin ich bin aufgewachsen in
einer Wohnung wo bei uns über 3000
Bücher einfach in einer Bücherei zu
Hause gab was fühlst du wenn du an deine
Kindheit in
in Syrien denkst
mir fällt das Land auf jeden Fall also
ich musste alles in meinem Leben
verlassen ich habe ein gutes Leben eine
gute Bildung alles mögliche wir hatten
aber Diktatoren im Land
das einfach darauf bestanden ist die
Bevölkerung einfach zu bekämpfen zu
toten was bedeutet Deutschland für dich
wenn du das vielleicht in zwei drei
Sätzen zusammenfassen könntest oder
müsstest mein Zuhause
Deutschland ist mein Zuhause ich bin in
Syrien geboren war fast gestorben in dem
Krieg bin hier angekommen und habe mich
wie neu geboren gefühlt Manuel wenn du
das jetzt hörst ich habe das Gefühl man
sieht ja anders macht was mit dir ja
selbstverständlich also ich hatte in
meinem Leben das Privileg immer
Demokratie Meinungsfreiheit zu haben
immer finanziell auch in sozialen System
abgesichert zu sein und da muss ich ganz
ehrlich sagen bin kürzester Zeit eine
wirklich schwere Sprache zu lernen sich
komplett hier zu integrieren und zu
sagen dieses Land ist mein Zuhause so
eine starke Aussage das ist Integration
und ich glaube es ist wichtig solche
Menschen zuzuhören weil das was er
erlebt hat das kann man emotional ich
sag mal jetzt in meiner Person gar nicht
richtig kann sich nicht realisieren und
ich bin sehr dankbar und ich bin vor
allem auch stolz sehr um die Leistung
und das finde ich sollte man auch ganz
deutlich machen das ist genau das Muster
weißer Menschen Menschen bewerten meiner
Integration hier nach sieben Jahren der
hat auch liebe Worte gesagt aber der hat
selbst dieses Muster nicht gecheckt die
weiße Menschen sind die Menschen die
einfach anderen bewerten dürfen
und ich als migrantisierter Person darf
ich nicht sagen was in dieser
Gesellschaft nicht passt also für mich
ist das ein Zuhause das heißt wenn ich
was fordere
dann geht's einfach mit der
Hintergrundgedanke nicht einfach
irgendwas so so zu kritisieren sondern
eher das Beste herauszuholen für ein
Land was für mich ein Zuhause ist
darf ich fragen es geht gar nicht darum
mit dem Finger zu zeigen und zu sagen
hey ihr seid alle Rassisten gar nicht
darum sondern auch zu zeigen was was das
mit mir macht und wie können wir
gemeinsam einfach einen anderen Stand
und haben Standpunkt haben von dem ich
nicht gestört wurde aber auch
gesetzlicher Maßnahmen umgesetzt wurden
wow der ganz kurz kannst du das so
annehmen
also ich akzeptiere das vollkommen ich
möchte dir die Situation so wie sie
jetzt hier ist in der Gesamtheit möchte
ich gerne so stehen Hammer
wirklich wirklich ich möchte euch
bisschen so so sehr danken wird ganz zum
Schluss noch eine Sache mit Euch beiden
versuchen
Tarek das mit der Nähe war für dich
heute die ganze Zeit Thema jetzt geht
ihr gleich hier raus geh dem du hier
raus
[Musik]
also ich habe ich habe nichts dagegen
wir können uns jetzt nutzen wir können
auch die Hände schützen aber für mich
ein Thema es geht gar nicht um wenn
Person von Manuel und am Ende wollte ich
ihm zeigen ich habe nichts gegen dir
persönlich sondern gegen deiner Position
deiner wo Lichtposition und deine
Äußerung ihr beiden ich weiß es verlangt
euch jetzt bestimmt noch mal mehr ab als
dass du vor allem dir aber jetzt sind
wir bei Tarek und Manuel schaffen wir so
eine verbrüdernde Geste um zusammen
gegenseitig Wünsche zu äußern
jetzt stehen die beiden hier Armen arm
wie Brüder ja eben nicht weil man hat
gemerkt ich musste sie dazu bringen und
zwar eine ganz schöne Reise und ich
glaube auch dass wenn die Umarmung
gleich vorbei ist und die hier rausgehen
ja die könnten vielleicht mal ein Bier
trinken gehen auf so einer ganz privaten
Ebene aber die stehen eben beide auch
für ein Thema und da hatte ich doch den
Eindruck bewegen die sich nicht du
darfst anfangen an dein dudes Freund
Manuel was ich mehr wünsche es eine
Studie zu Rassismus bei der Polizei die
bestätigen kann ob es solche Verhältnis
zeigt oder nicht mein erster Wunsch ist
dass wir tatsächlich gemeinsam bemüht
sind in dem Austausch zu bleiben und
zwar durch regelmäßige Treffen die wir
organisieren können damit wir glaube ich
noch so den ein oder anderen
differenzbezug aus der Welt hören können
und uns vielleicht innerlich für eine
gemeinsame Sache annehmen
ich wünsche dir auf jeden Fall als der
Person ohne das zu erleben was ich
erleben musste einfach mal ein binden
die Welt zu sehen wie ich das sehe das
prägt einem und ändert einfach den
Blickwinkel
bleib so wie du bist bleib Meinung stark
bleibt kommunikativ setzt dich weiter
ehrenamtlich ein für eine Sache die ich
vielleicht inhaltlich nicht immer Teile
aber die grundsätzlich richtig ist genau
das brauchen wir in Deutschland und dann
möchte ich Dir tatsächlich Danke sagen
für den heutigen Tag wir sind zwar nicht
überall einer Meinung aber ich glaube
dass wir uns ein bisschen angenäht sind
auch thematische man Riesenschritt in
die richtige Richtung ich danke dir ich
danke euch beiden wirklich von Herzen
dafür dass ihr da wart Tarek vielen
vielen Dank für alles was Du heute so
hart so klar und so finde ich auch
persönlich vertreten hast und
gleichzeitig immer diesen Blick aufs
große ganz wieder gebracht hast Manuel
danke dafür dass du da warst danke dafür
dass du dagegen gehalten hast danke
dafür dass du auch versucht dass dich zu
bewegen und das ihr uns beide wirklich
allen noch mal glaube ich komplett neue
Sichtweisen auf dieses Thema hat
zumindest hoffe ich mir das bei mir hat
es an vielen Stellen noch mal klick
gemacht was ich vorher vielleicht so gar
nicht gedacht hätte danke schön
dann bis dahin
ich werde mir das ganz oben auf die
Fahne schreiben noch mehr Debatte
zuzulassen noch mehr auf die Menschen
einzugehen sie zu verstehen wir haben
diskutiert jeder hat seine Standpunkt
verteidigt aber so viele Erkenntnisse
für mich gibt es nicht weil das war zu
erwarten was er gesagt hat ich war am
Ende so froh dass ich die beiden dann
doch irgendwie näher gekommen sind dass
es fast die Umarmung gab richtig
erleichtert weil die am Anfang ja
überhaupt keinen Bock aufeinander hat es
wurde sich gesiegt und dann diese
Annäherung zum Schluss
[Musik]